We're in a series on James.
If you're new today, we have started a series a few weeks ago on the book of James, which is just such a fantastic book.
You say, what do you love about the book of James?
First of all, it's super practical.
It's very basic.
That's why we've titled it The Essentials, a study of the book of James, because it's really just about some basics of the faith.
And you're going to see that today.
It's also a very easy book.
to apply.
In fact, when I was reading this week through different commentaries, the passage we're looking at, here's what many commentators said needs no explanation.
We all can understand what it's saying.
It's one of those things, it wouldn't much help to me, but it was the truth.
It's very simple, very easy to understand, and it's important for you and I to every now and then test ourselves.
Paul says,
1 Corinthians 13, 5, examine yourselves, test yourself to see whether you be in the faith.
It's good for you and I to look at our life and say, are the things in our life, not only interactions but our attitudes, in our words, are those things lining up with what God has called us to do and to be personally, individually?
So what James does is really the book is a series of areas in which you and I can evaluate our life and see how we're doing in living the Christian faith.
James starts by talking about trials.
He says, there's a certain way you and I should go through trials and it starts with counting it all as joy.
Then he talks about temptation, how temptation is formed and what happens and he gives us that evaluation.
How do we handle temptation?
And then as you come into this section of James, he's talking about how you and I hear the word and the test today is how you and I apply the word.
Are we doing what the word of God says?
In James 1 verse 22, do not merely listen to the word and so deceive yourselves, do what it says.
And then what he does at the end of the chapter is he gives us three criteria by which we can measure whether or not we are actually doing what the word says.
In James 1 verse 26, if anyone considers himself religious,
And yet does not keep a tight rein on his tongue.
He deceives himself and his religion is worthless.
Religion that God our Father accepts as pure and faultless is this.
To look after orphans and widows in their distress and to keep oneself from being polluted by the world.
Notice he talks about being religious, about religion and about religion.
The word religions come on hard times in our day.
People don't want to be identified either as religious or as affiliated with religion because oftentimes it speaks of the failure of people, often leaders who have pursued things in the name of Christ that were really not about Christ.
And so what we have today is we have people who say, well, you know, I'm spiritual.
I'm not religious.
And the problem is the I'm spiritual can become code for a self-styled approach to religion that is totally detached from biblical Christianity.
But regardless of whether a person claims to be spiritual or religious, James gives us three criteria for measuring our
the vitality of our spirituality or our religious conviction in life.
The first criterion is very simple to understand our conversation.
James says this, if anyone considers himself religious and yet does not keep a tight reign on his tongue, he deceives himself and his religion is worthless.
The word worthless there could be his religion is an idol.
In other words, if you can't control your tongue, part of the problem is that your self-expression has become an idol.
It's become more important to you than God.
And it can manifest itself in a lot of ways.
It can be, well, I know the Bible says, but I think, or it can be people who will say things
And you're telling, hey, you shouldn't be talking like, well, I know but.
Or they get on social media and they put things out there that should not be said.
And what James is saying is if we don't learn to keep a tight rein on our tongue, then our religion's worthless.
Out of the abundance of the heart, Jesus said the mouth speaks.
What comes out of our mouth is indicative of what's in our heart.
And the real question is, how do we rein in our tongue?
And this is a very big issue to James.
One of the things that James points to repeatedly in the book is simply that we will be judged by our words and we need to recognize that.
That we will give an account.
that we will be judged on what we have said.
In James chapter two and verse 12, speak and act as those who are going to be judged by the law that gives freedom.
You could put it this way.
This would be speaking such a manner and acting such a manner as those who are about to be judged by the law of liberty.
The idea is it's a continual action.
In other words, in everything we say, we need to recognize that we're gonna give account for what we said.
James continues this idea in James chapter three and verse one, when he says, dear brothers and sisters, not many of you should become teachers in the church, for we who teach will be judged more strictly.
In other words, there's an accountability.
There is a judgment for what people will say.
Jesus says on the day of judgment, he says, men will give an account of every idle word they've spoken.
You and I will be held accountable.
In James chapter four and verse 11, brothers do not slander one another.
Anyone who speaks against his brother or judges him speaks against the law and judges it.
Do not slander.
The word in the Greek is kara-leo.
It's kara-la-la-la-la-la-la.
It's not a pathetic word.
That means it means what it sounds like.
It's like blah, blah, blah, blah.
I've ever met somebody and you just want to say that to me.
I say blah, blah, blah.
I mean, that's not very Christian, but in...
They just go on and on.
and it's to mindlessly or carelessly talk someone down.
The King James translates the word as slander, as backbiting, and he does it because often when people are doing that, the other person, the person being spoken against isn't around and has no opportunity to defend themselves.
And I'm just gonna say this has become
not just epidemic, but pandemic in the church.
Church people have since COVID, and you can talk to any pastor you want, and they will say, true.
Church people have become mean, they become nasty, they become critical on social media, and the world sees it.
I don't know how many people I've had who are not Christians who apologize to me and say, I feel so sorry for you.
I'm so sorry for what's happened to you online.
And I would never want to be a Christian because the people who are doing this to your Christians.
I'm just simply saying at some point we've got to rein it in.
At some point we've got to realize this is not
This is actually a terrible testimony to the world.
And James says that we have to be careful about not slandering.
And notice he says, brothers, one another, brother, him.
The idea is we're all in this community.
We're in a family.
There's a family of believers.
You can't have slander within a family or your family will disintegrate.
You know, I've told this before, but a lot of people ask how come David, Brandon, and Svan are so close, and they speculate it's because they're very close and age, 30 months from the oldest to the youngest.
But it's more than that.
It simply is an acknowledgement on my part, and I think part of it was being a little brother, and I love my brother.
But I think part of it was recognizing what, and I'm not against healthy competition,
I'm against unhealthy competition, and I'm against people saying words, and when they let those words go, they don't realize that person might live with those words forever.
So as parents, we had zero tolerance for any kind of put downs, any kinds of competition that
worked against the other person, not that everybody has to win and everybody's a winner.
I don't believe that to be true either.
But whenever I saw them fighting, saying things, doing things like that, and I can remember we were doing it in Colby and in Kansas City, so they'd have been three or four years old, I would make them stand and face one another.
I think I got a choice here.
You can have a correction.
or you can stand and face one another.
And I want you to look at one another and you know they're looking at one another and don't look at me and don't be looking around.
You look right at the other and then I would sit there and talk to him.
The person you're looking at is your brother.
He will have your back when no one else does.
He is your best friend and you will stand up for him and you will love him and I would give him this big pep talk
And then I would say, now, I want you to both hug one another.
And they would hug one another.
And it was hard to keep from laughing at times because it was just so cute.
But even as they got into grade school, I'd make them stand a lick at one another and say it because I wanted to teach them there is no place ever in a family for any kind of derogatory commentary
on another person.
And can I just say, there's no place ever in the church of the living God.
I'm not talking about in James River, I'm talking about the church of the living God for derogatory commentary that in many times cases is slander, there's no place for it.
And James says this, it's very interesting, when you speak against a brother, you're speaking against the law and judging it, you say,
How am I doing that?
What you're saying is, I know what the law says, but I don't care.
I want to say what I want to say.
The law is not as important as my opinion.
And James says, when you do that, you're judging the law.
You're saying it's not valuable and you will be judged by the Lord.
In 2 Corinthians chapter 5 and verse 10, for we must all appear before the judgment seat of Christ.
This is believers.
Did each one may receive what is due him for things done while in the body where they're good or bad?
We're getting given account before the Lord of how we stewarded life as a follower of Christ.
And honestly, that in itself ought to bring great pause to every single one of us.
And we need to think about a bigger picture of loving one another because Jesus said,
They'll know you are Christians by your what?
Love.
I think a second way to reign in our words is to recognize the power of our words.
Proverbs, chapter 8, verse 21, the tongue can bring death or life.
You can literally crush somebody with your word.
There are some of you here today, and when I even talk about the idea of words hurting or the pain of somebody's words, some of your 20 years removed from the time somebody said something to you, and it still crushes you.
Or your words can bring life.
because somebody said they believed in you, because somebody was for you, because somebody said, I see something in you, and today that still motivates you in life.
That's the power of words, and it can bring death or life.
Those who love to talk will reap the consequences.
Proverbs says in another place, in an abundance of words, there is much folly.
Think one proverb puts it this way, when words or many sin is not absent.
And we have to realize that the more we're speaking, and it ought to cause every single one of us who does it for a living, whether you're a preacher, a teacher, whether you're somebody whose job requires continual communication, maybe you're in sales, you just gotta realize that there is a danger, the more your mouth is open, the greater opportunity there is for sin.
And so we have to think about it.
We have to realize what it can do.
And really, I would say this, on the one hand, certainly can damage people
But for all of us to look for opportunities to change the atmosphere and the environment of a place, to walk in a word, Fittley's spoken the writer of Proverbs says, is like apples of gold and setting of silver.
It's just like awesome, it's beautiful, it's fitting, it's appropriate, it can lift people up, it can be a wellspring of life to people.
And we have that ability.
So let me just give you a little acrostic for our words and for processing it.
Think before you speak.
T, is it true?
Not did somebody tell it to you.
Do you know it's true?
And I would say this, I hope there are things people have told you that you've kept
to yourself either because you knew it wasn't true or you weren't sure it was true, or second, you thought, you know what, even if it is true, it doesn't help.
I'm not talking about covering sin.
And there's a means for covering sin, you go to the person face to face.
But think, is it true number or H?
Is it helpful?
Is it gonna help them?
Is it going to build them up?
Is it going to help bring healing to the situation?
Is it inspiring?
Is it going to lift them?
Is it going to cause them to want to be better?
And is it necessary?
Does it really need to be said?
Listen, not everything that could be said on a subject really needs to be said.
Is it necessary for your eye to say it?
Maybe somebody else ought to be the person who says it.
Okay, is it kind?
Is it kind?
D.L.
Moody, a preacher in the 1800 says this, said this, the hardest thing God has to do is to make his people kind.
He can make them preachers, he can make them singers, but the hardest thing he has to do is to make people kind.
The verse that runs through my mind continually, and I would encourage you to memorize it as Ephesians 4 and verse 29.
Do not let any unwholesome talk come out of your mouth, but only what is helpful for building others up according to their needs.
Watch this.
That it might benefit those who listen.
Is it gonna benefit people?
Is it gonna lift people?
Is it gonna build people?
So Paul says, be careful of saying things, posting things, texting things that don't fit that criteria.
Number two, a second criteria.
So our words, our conversation is the first criteria by which we measure our faith.
The second criteria is our compassion.
James chapter one in verse 27, religion that God our Father accepts as pure and faultless is this, to look after orphans and widows in their distress.
I don't know whether you're aware of this, but in the last 30 years, the number of orphans worldwide has gone from 15 million to 140 million.
That's just stunning to think about that.
And the plight of orphans and the plight of widows and the plight of helpless people is very, very close to the heart of God.
In fact, when God identifies himself, here's part of how God himself identifies himself.
In Psalm 68, father of orphans, champion of widows is God in his holy house.
He's the champion.
If you're a single woman, he is the champion of women who are in a situation where there's a need, where they don't have somebody to watch over them, he's a champion.
If you're an orphan, he's a father.
If you never had a father that was a godly father or a good father, you never knew your father.
God is your father, and he delights in being your father and says, hey, guess what?
I'm a father to every orphan.
Not only does he want to be known by that, but the God who cares about the plight of people does something about it.
He makes homes for the homeless.
He's the one who cares about people.
He puts them in families, one translation says.
And this has always been the heart of God in Exodus chapter 22.
Don't mistreat widows or orphans.
If you do and they cry out to me, you can be sure I'll take them most seriously.
I'll show my anger and come raging among you with the sword and your wives will end up widows and your children orphans.
It's very strong.
Deuteronomy chapter 27 verse 19, cursed is anyone who denies justice to foreigners, to orphans or to widows.
I'm gonna tell you what, if you're loaning money at an exorbitant rate to people who fall in this category, look out.
So I'm just making a living.
Listen.
There are people who are stimming people alive and God hates it.
You have to think about this.
Isaiah 117, learn to do good, seek justice, help the oppressed, defend the cause of orphans, fight for the rights of widows.
This is so near to the heart of God and
Some of you are newer so you're not aware of things, but in the history of James River, we've taken this very seriously.
And I'm not saying we're doing everything that could be done.
I'm just simply saying we're doing many things people don't know are being done.
One child sponsors children around the world and James River because of your generosity since 2009 has sponsored 8,910 children.
Debbie and I sponsor five children.
Debbie's gone to Haiti and visited them.
I mean, we have to care for people who can't care for themselves.
And those children are getting a meal.
They're getting meals.
They're getting the things they need for schooling.
They're getting an education.
They're still, in most cases, living with their family, but their family cannot do for them.
What needs to be done?
We write letters and notes to them every month.
There's a way to do that, to encourage them, and they're so precious when they write you back.
Through kingdom impact, we're helping orphanages around the world.
I think of the one in Baguio City, the Philippines, Family Circus is what it's called.
It's in a Muslim area.
And there are hundreds of kids that are at it.
And the Blatchleys have led it for decades now.
And the Muslim people respect them.
Why?
Because they're caring for orphans.
Through cherished kids, we have raised up hundreds of foster families in the Green and Christian County area.
Many of you have gone through the classes.
Today the classes are online.
Others have adopted.
Donna Lanelle Hamilton recently went through a foster care class and are caring for a little boy and doing such a beautiful job.
But before that, they were caring for family.
Nieces and nephews who needed care.
I mean, you know, sometimes I died.
I'm highlighting them because they're on the platform.
I think sometimes you don't know.
the kind of people who are actually ministering to you are ministering to a lot of other people and care deeply about people.
Our community care department ministers to hundreds of single moms and widows every year.
First Timothy chapter five and verse three, take care of any widow who has no one else to care for her.
And what's interesting is the word there for widow in the Greek is the word carer.
And it's not limited to women whose husbands have died, but it's used to describe women who are left alone due to death, divorce, or desertion.
It's a woman who's left alone either by herself or left alone with children to care for.
And we need to have a heart for people in that situation.
Remember, Debbie was
At one of the grocery stores and she saw a lady getting cupcakes, she assumed was for a class birthday party, and Debbie stepped in front of her and said, she didn't know her, she just felt like the Lord wanted to do it.
And again, this is not about Debbie.
I'm giving it as an example to say, listen, this is the kind of way we have to think.
So she stepped in front of her and she said, if you don't mind, I'd like to pay for those.
The lady said, thank you.
And that was it.
Debbie didn't hear anything else until about a year later.
And the woman was coming to James River.
And she said, I started coming to church because of what you did.
You did not know it.
But I had no money.
And I didn't even know.
She said it was the stupidest thing.
I didn't even know why I was getting these because I knew I couldn't pay for them.
It was for my daughter's class birthday party.
Listen, you don't know, but if we don't sensitize our heart to the plight and the needs of people around us.
If we don't treat people with dignity, send the elevator to the hospital, punch the button.
It's a man standing there.
I turned to him, I said, how are you doing today?
He said, not real good.
I said, what's wrong?
He went on to tell me I'm homeless.
I would not have known by looking at him that he was.
But he set us up outside all night.
And a heart should break.
Too often, we're very willing to help people overseas who we don't know anything about, but we look at people here in the US, and we're like, well, why don't you get a job?
Instead of wondering what kind of trauma happened in their life, were they beat as a child, were they
Were they raised out on the street?
Are they a veteran who is so messed up from fighting for a country that they can't do life anymore?
Are they a woman who's been abused over and over again so that now she trusts no one and has nowhere to turn and wishes she could die?
But every single day is a living hell for her.
Something inside us
Should be bothered not judging people bothered for these people and to say how can I help them?
I Know law enforcement says don't give people money But I can't Drive by people who are on a street corner and have nothing
How bad off do you have to say, are they working games and they make lots of money?
Really, would you like to live on it?
Most cases, not enough to get them off the street and not just give them money, but stop long enough if you can to ask them their name and to give value to them.
Can you imagine your world's possessions
in a backpack.
I'm just simply saying, wherever you see people, if you see them at a gas station, feed them, help them, love them, give a cup of cold water in the name of Jesus.
Jesus says, if you've done it to the least of these, my brothers, you did it to me.
You say, I don't know anybody like that.
I'm not around people like that.
Well, I've got good news for you.
We got a Saturday serve coming up, and we're going to be ministering to the homeless.
We're going to be ministering to veterans.
I just pray that not just James River, but the believers in this area are known as people who are compassionate and care.
for the hurting and the helpless, for the people who have no one to stand up for them.
And if you don't care, something's wrong with your faith.
Third criteria, looked at our conversation or compassion.
Now James talks about our consecration.
Look at it in verse 27.
Religion that God our Father accepts as pure and faultless as this.
To look after orphans and widows in their distress and to keep oneself from being polluted by the world.
You notice three words, keep polluted and world.
Keep.
Say I did, it's military term, it's like you've got military apparatus, you've got military devices, it's like you're armed and dangerous, it's like you are armed and dangerous when it comes to sin, you will take it out.
You're not gonna give sin any opportunity, any advantage.
What we're talking about here is not just a passive approach to sin, but an active approach that says, I will kill sin, so it doesn't kill me.
It's the idea of vigilant.
It's the idea of being ready.
It's not casual, it's intentional.
And then there's polluted.
It's a picture of being spiritually contaminated by the world.
Do you realize that in the same way that I'm in here on Friday night and the presence of the Lord is on me?
Do you realize that by where I go, what I do, what I watch, what I embrace,
that hangs on you.
If you think you can embrace the things of the world and not have it stick to you, you're mistaken.
And then there's the world itself and we're not talking about people and we're not talking about the planet.
What we're talking about is the system that runs without God.
in its values, its appetites, its entertainment, its philosophies, its the anti-God, no God, don't need Him philosophy of our world.
And we have to understand, John says this, 1 John 519, that the world around us is under the control of the evil one.
Surely that has become more obvious to us now than ever as we look around.
And here's the danger.
It's a little bit like what we talked about in Hebrews.
Nobody just falls into sin.
I don't believe that.
What happens is slowly, imperceptibly, by inches, they move towards allowing sin to contaminate their life.
A little compromise here.
Little justification over there.
A little, you know, I'm not a legalist.
I mean, at times I just wish the church were more.
I'm not gonna preach that.
I'm saying that facetiously.
But I, in the desire to not be bound by standards, the church has gotten to a place where it has no standards.
And people flaunt their freedom as an excuse
to do, oh yeah, we do this, we do that, do all the things that people didn't used to do.
And I'm not saying we should go back to that, but I am saying that in the desire to be free from legalism, people have found themselves contaminated by sin.
And what happens is,
Over time, they live more and more like the world.
They talk like the world.
They think like the world.
And the tragedy is what used to bother them.
No longer bothers them at all.
That's why James says, James chapter four, verse four, don't you realize the friendship with the world makes you an enemy of gods?
I say again, if you want to be a friend of the world, you make yourself an enemy of God.
a super strong language.
James is trying to get our attention.
He's saying, listen, if you're so much like the world that people have no idea you're a Christian, something's wrong.
And the thing that's wrong is not only what's happening in your heart, but what's happening in your relationship with God, and you're deceived in this sense, you thought you were a friend of God, but because of your embrace of the world, you're actually
in terms of relationship and enemy of God.
He has to hold you at arm's length.
Second, first John chapter two and verse 15, do not love this world nor the things it offers you.
For when you love the world, you do not have the love of the Father in you.
This is really strong words.
I mean, where's your heart?
What do you love?
Let's put it this way.
What do you think about when you get up and what do you think about when you go to bed?
That's what you love.
The first thing you think about when you get up in the morning, what's the last thing you think about when you go to bed at night, that's what you love.
And if God isn't in that, something is wrong.
First Peter 2, 11.
Dear friends, I warn you as temporary residents and foreigners, he's saying, listen, this world is gonna pass and everything in it.
Everything you and I have is on loan from God.
Our time here is so brief in light of eternity, it's temporary.
He's saying, keep away from worldly desires.
Why?
because they wage war against your soul.
It's about refusing to let anything stain your soul that Jesus died to make clean.
You have to be careful.
So let me ask you, what do you defend now that used to cause you to repent?
What do you excuse now that at one time made you confess?
And if Jesus physically came to your house, what would you need to turn off or hide or put away or hope he didn't see or know?
Listen, he's coming back, Jesus is for a bride
without spot or blemish.
He's coming back for a holy church, a holy people.
And the idea is not, how much can I do and still be saved?
The idea is, what do I need to get rid of that I might be as close to God as I possibly can?
How do we stay clean?
Just quickly.
Number one, repent.
Name it, own it,
Stop it.
Don't just feel bad about it.
Confess it and stop doing it.
Tell somebody you're doing it and then stop doing it.
Number two, replace.
You won't win by simply trying harder.
We win by replacing some things.
For some of you, means you're gonna have to replace your priorities.
You're gonna have to rearrange some things.
You're gonna have to say, listen, I've got to live life differently if I'm gonna live life differently, right?
That might mean changing how you spend your time.
I'm gonna tell you what, the best thing you could do in the middle of the week is to be at the permitting.
It's like an oasis spiritually in the middle of the week in the same way that Friday night had that effect.
I mean, I never said anything to Debbie.
She just was simply saying to Brandon in conversation, the next day, I could tell the hand of God was all over your father when he talked to me on Friday night.
Listen, that'd be true on Thursday morning for you.
So maybe you need to be in church instead of getting ready for the rest of your week.
God will multiply the time back to you.
Maybe you need to change your friends.
Maybe you need to spend less time with some people and more time with others.
You see, no one drifts toward holiness.
We all drift toward compromise if we allow it.
And we need people in our life who will inspire us to live in purity by the example of their life.
It doesn't mean you'll do what they do, but I'm gonna tell you what, it'll make you think.
It's last week, any castle or centae.
I'm using the music too, because I think sometimes you need to know, you know, the idea of getting up and singing the song is secondary to the hand of the Lord being here, and that is true through the team in an amazing degree.
And he sends the text out to the teammate.
She says, hey, I'm getting ready to do this.
Never done it before in my life, but I'm texting you.
So I'll actually do it and not back out.
But I'm going to spend the night praying all night long.
I've never done it.
Never prayed all night long.
And I'm going to do it.
And I want to be you to hold me accountable.
And you know, I'd heard about that.
I wasn't on that text thread.
But then today before service,
I had a chance just to ask Annie about that.
It's very challenging, very inspiring, very wonderful.
Do the people around you call you to go deeper in God or do they call you to move away from God in your commitment?
Number three, recommit.
Recommit to a life of consecration.
Can I just say churches in a box you check
off your list, like, you know, I'm in church for a while, probably, I ought to go.
It's a rhythm you do that keeps you spiritually strong.
It just makes a massive difference.
When you're in church, it makes a massive difference.
Because what happens is, whether it's the Word, whether it's the worship, whether it's the interaction with people, it reorients, it recalibrates your life so that you really get a true North.
And again, that's why I'm saying,
I would just, better than any production we would ever do at Christmas, you know, Easter in the place packed and all of that.
Being here in the presence of the Lord tonight would be, I'm just telling you, it is going to be extraordinary.
And it won't be a show, but it will be an encounter.
You want to encounter God, be here.
I'm just telling you, I was,
I know of what I speak.
I know how seriously they take it.
James' point here is true religion shows up in three places.
Our conversation, our mouth is it under the authority of King Jesus.
Our compassion, do we automatically move toward the hurting?
And our consecration, are we sensitive to the things that stain or pollute
our heart.
I want to ask you this.
I'm going to close with this.
What is the step of obedience that God is speaking to your heart today?
Can you identify what it is?
What are you going to walk out of here saying, I need to do this.
I have this action step.
For some, it will be related to your mouth.
You're gonna need to say to people you've slandered, I'm sorry.
Listen, don't just stop, you need to make a right.
And honestly, that will help you from doing it, not doing it again.
And it'll bring a restoration in the process.
Maybe it's no more criticism, no more gossip, no more colors, words.
Maybe it's rather than speaking negativity.
I'm gonna come into the places where I, whether it's at home or at work or wherever I'm at, that I'm going to speak life and blessing over people.
For some, it has to do with mercy.
You've let life become about you in a way that's blinded you to the plight of others.
Listen, I'm just saying, the needs are so huge just in our area
You could work every single Saturday and never meet them all.
And you say, well, then why?
What are we trying to do?
Because it makes a difference when we try.
And it does change some lives.
Kind of like the story of the kid who was walking along the beach and he saw a man and he was picking up starfish and throwing him back in the ocean.
And the kids, they're all kinds of starfish there.
And the kid said, why are you doing that?
I mean, I didn't want that.
There's all these.
You can't help them all.
It won't make a difference.
And the man picked up another one.
He said, make a difference to this one.
And we might not be able to touch everybody, but you can't touch someone.
For some, it's holding a shoe bin drifting.
I don't know what it cost you to driftless in life's life.
But today, you're going to draw a line in the sand, and you're going to say, I'm done drifting.
And I am not going to accept into my life the things that would pollute my soul.
A heart and a place Jesus died to make clear.